real quick I want to tell you about one
of our sponsors bespoke post it's a
subscription Club for men with every
monthly box they send you their aim is
to help you freshen up your daily life
in one box I got these great handmade
sunglasses that I really like it came
with this really nice leather case and a
microfiber cloth to keep him clean in
another box I got a set of high quality
German beer glasses and a fantastic
growler every box they send you is
packed with really interesting unique
gear guaranteed to be worth more than
what you're spending on the subscription
you can return or exchange boxes you can
skip a month cancel whenever you want
click the link underneath this video to
take their quiz and get suggestions
about which bespoke post boxes might be
best for you coming off of a pretty
mediocre debate performance Joe Biden
almost immediately went to a restaurant
and made a sort of bizarre comment about
a gay waiter that is again just making
me wonder about Joe Biden's judgement in
telling these stories and anecdotes this
is two days after the debate on Saturday
there was a fundraiser for Joe Biden
hosted by a public relations executive
in Seattle and Biden was I guess trying
to talk about how far we've come as a
society on gay rights and he said to the
crowd five years ago if someone in
Seattle made fun of a gay waiter at a
restaurant people would have just quote
let it go and people in the crowd found
it really odd and they actually started
yelling out no we wouldn't have five
years ago in Seattle we wouldn't have
let someone made making fun of the gay
waiter just go and the pool report from
the event sums it up as Biden saying
basically if today someone made a
homophobic comment in Seattle to a gay
waiter that person would not be invited
back to the restaurant they'd be asked
to leave and would be told not to come
back but that five years ago you could
get away with that in Seattle you could
get away with making in front of a gay
waiter so look at how far we've come now
it's a strange comment I get the idea
which is we've just come so far but the
problem is that it makes Joe Biden seem
out of touch with Seattle because
Seattle has been very much on the
forefront of gay rights it's been very
forward-thinking so it seems kind of out
of touch to suggest that in one
14 which is pretty late in the game for
the more progressive states that making
fun of a gay waiter would be acceptable
in any sense so I I do want to say this
is a bit of a pylon with Joe Biden there
is a lot to criticize Joe Biden for Joe
Biden is not someone I'm interested in
voting for in the Democratic primary Joe
Biden's debate performance wasn't good
Joe Biden straight up said he's not for
Medicare for all he wants to tweak
Obamacare there's a ton of stuff to
criticize Joe Biden about he has a
strange history of saying positive
things about segregationist elected
officials but overall he is actually
saying the right things about LGBT
rights he pointed out that even though
gay marriage is now legal in 50 states
you can still get fired over your sexual
orientation in 22 states that's a huge
issue it doesn't get nearly enough
attention Joe Biden is right to bring it
up and I'm glad that he's doing it the
comment about Seattle it's dumb it shows
he doesn't really know very much about
Seattle Seattle was way ahead on this
stuff they passed the Fair Employment
Practice ordinance in the early 70s
they've had benefits for same-sex
partners for a long time in Washington
state for as long as Joe Biden has been
in politics maybe some of this stuff
does feel relatively recent like when
you've been in politics as long as Joe
Biden something happening in 2014 or
2004 might feel almost like the same
thing I actually don't think we should
be making as big of a deal about this
because Joe Biden basically is right on
gay rights in almost all cases at this
point in time there are much bigger fish
to fry when it comes to Joe Biden so if
you believe that Joe Biden making this
comment is anything more than just being
out of touch with Seattle politics over
the last couple of decades I'm open to
having my mind changed if people in the
audience want to get in touch and tell
me how I'm misinterpreting it out of
touch comment Joe Biden bringing up
important issues actually about gay
rights and there are far bigger
criticisms that we can and should be
making about Joe Biden's policy in other
areas including on health care